我现在跟我公公婆婆住在一块儿的，然后我老公，然后他们现在做了一个小生意，就是市菜市场那边的那种。然后我现在是223妈嘛，嗯，我老大4岁上幼儿园了，我老二现在才三个月，我自己带着两个孩子，然后我们之间有很多很多的矛盾。去年他爸妈回到老家半年，然后今年过年，因为我怀孕了他又过来帮忙了。现在就是我面对的一个一个问题，我该怎么去？就是说是切割。因为我老婆是很怕他爸爸，因为他爸爸是那种特别强势的那种人。本来之前他们家其实表面上过得挺和谐的，除了他爸。然后他妈他跟我老公都挺能忍的。我来了之后，我就忍不了，然后就跟中间这个矛盾就很大，就爆发了。那我问问你啊，就是你们现在在婆家生活，主要挣你是靠谁？主要挣你是靠公公呢，还是靠你老公？就是他们三个人在家里面。
主要的话，原来是之前前段时间一直是我老公，主要是我老公。然后这段时间我老公出现了一个问题，就好他心肌炎了，去检查就是心脏疼。心脏疼去大医院去检查是心肌炎。然后他这个病需要养，不能熬夜，不能抽烟，不能劳累，然后他没办法，太疼了。然后他现在主要是他爸爸，然后主要是他爸，然后是你老公和婆婆都在店里，那家个庭的年收入大概一年能收多少钱呀？具体的我不知道，但是大概的话，我知道30多个吧。哦，那你现在你一个人带两个娃也挺辛苦的，没有人帮你吗？家里娘家人也没人帮你吗？没有我跟你做这个月子，我现在跟我娘家人也不联系了，因为我婆跟婆我婆家一有矛盾，我这么说吧，反正之前有一次矛盾，我公公婆婆跑到我娘家去吃饭。我公公指着我爸妈鼻子骂我爸妈都不吭声的那一种。我妈妈还之前说过这样一句话，她说是养女儿是善。从小我们在家的时候，她就觉得我们养的女儿不如别人家的女儿能干勤快，就是这样的。我还有个妹妹也过得非常不幸福。所以说，娘家是没有依靠的，我也不喜欢他们哦，那现在你生活在婆家，婆家主要是经济大权在谁手上啊嗯，现在微信号虽然嗯收款码是我老公，但是这个钱是。
嗯，就是我老公的一个小微信小号，微信号收钱，所以这个钱我们是大家都在用，但是大权在谁的，谁的手上就不来说呢。我感觉都嗯，谁的手上都不在。但是他嗯，以前的话是在我公公手上的，然后去年他回去了，就转到我老公手上了。转到我老公手上，但是都在用，大家都有没也没有管在谁的一个人手上收款的那个号，反正是你老公的实名认证，所以呢，你老公他是能够控制家里面的财政的对不对？好，那你现在想要问龙飞姐的问题是什么呀？其实我自己能就是说看了很多人的心理书，您推荐的书我基本上都买了，我都看，我其实自己能知道这个问题的根本在哪，其实就在于我老公他不愿意去脱离出来，我现在就不知道怎么办。我来跟你讲啊，第一，咱们原生家庭给不到我们足够的保护支持依靠。第二，嗯，现在咱们有两个孩子了，在这种情况下，怎么能够一让自己日子过得舒畅，二让这两个孩子能够健康的快乐的长大，可能会成为我们生活当中最主要的一个课题，对不对？
对好，那么我们就分析一下现有的手上几张牌，就现在我们有什么？如果原生家庭不能给我支持，不能给我依靠，我现在自己一个人带两个孩子，又不能挣钱，不能工作好，我还有什么？我有一个现在身体还不错，能挣钱的公公，但脾气不太好，控制欲比较强。我有一个还能帮衬帮衬店里面去挣钱的婆婆，我有一个现在有心肌炎，但是身体不太对吧，身体不太好，但是对我还不错的老公，这3张牌是我能拥有的东西没错吧？我怎么把这3张牌打好？当我自己没有能力挣钱的时候，我自己还在带着两个小孩，还得依靠公公婆婆去挣米的时候，我就得把他们当成座上宾来看待。
就得把他们当成我生命中最重要的资源来看待，一旦你把他们当成座上宾，把他们当成你的帮手，把他们当成你的能够帮衬你拉扯孩子的助手来看待的时候，你会宽容很多。
就人家是真金白银在说白了就在帮你挣钱呢，帮你和孩子挣钱呢，对吧，帮助你拉扯孩子呢。在这种情况下的话，情绪价值一定要给到位。什么叫情绪价值给到位？公公回来的时候，给人倒杯热水。哎，公公回来的时候，对吧，问一句，爹累了吧？我给你倒杯水，你想吃水果吗？我给你洗个水果。我那个什么打断一下，我感觉这一点是做不到的，因为我们吵过两架了。我公公还打过，也不是说他打我，就是我们今天手冲突来差点动手了，但是没有动到手，准备动手完了之后，就是说作为一个公公哈，吵架的时候他污言秽语的就是骂我，我还回去了。我这人脾气特，我就是嘴巴贱，然后我我也脾气忍不了，我就嘴巴贱，然后就是，他骂我一句，我就是原话，就回去了。就是这样子。
啊，然后我们现在关系很糟糕，特别糟糕。就是虽然住在一个房子里边，因为我们是在外地，然后自己买的房子又不可能出去租房子，这样代价太大了。所以说，我们就住在一房子里面，但是我们就不说话。而且，我也特别特别就是抵触跟着我公公见面，我就有一种那种，我跟他见面，我就浑身不舒服，我就嗯很难受，那你希望龙飞姐帮你解决的问题是什么呀？因您刚刚已经说了，该怎么去相处，人生如戏，全靠演技。你不要把它当成是我真的屈服了，我真的在怎么怎么样，它就是一场戏，就如果我们把这场戏演好了，那公公婆婆还能帮我们再干20年，还能帮我们再挣20年的钱，还能帮我们拉扯孩子，孩子到时候就大了，就在现有的状态下。我们一定要认清什么局势，局势是什么？一、娘家人不能给我依靠，二、我现在有两个小孩，三我自己现在没有办法工作，没有人帮衬我拉扯孩子，对吧，没有任何人能帮我拉扯这俩孩子。与此同时，我又不可能说这俩孩子我不要了，我拎着腿我就走了，对吧？我已去奔赴自己的新生活了，我又不掉，但是好委屈啊。我感觉，因为我感。
感觉嗯，或许我就是狭隘了。嗯，我觉得他虽然是在挣钱，帮我挣钱，但是孩子，我我又没有乱花钱，所有的钱就花在我孩子身上。我公公开口闭口就是说我用钱花钱用钱用多了，怎么什么的账单全部拉出来看了哈，我一个月全部的所有开销全部都算完了的话，也才8000块钱不到。我就想不明白，为啥就很难接受这个事情？没事儿啊，没事儿，姑娘，人是特别容易被情绪控制的，这是属于正常的。但什么样的人能够把日子过好呢？就是能够跳脱出来。
认真分析局面的人才能把日子过好，就如果有一天你能认真想一想龙飞姐刚才帮你分析的这个局面，然后跳脱出这个情绪，你的日子一定能过好。龙姐相信这一点。
就有的时候，他是一个嗯叫什么打破一个生活模式，就是现在这个生活模式，就是我很委屈，我又没有乱花钱，我每天都在带着两个孩子，这两个孩子还还不是你跟你们姓吗？还不是你们家的孙子吗？我在为你们家付出，为什么我没有得到尊重？好，如果从这个思路去考虑这个问题的话，那你永远都是委屈的，他们家人不管对你怎么样，你都是委屈的。因为你一直是站在一个我付出了一切，我为你们家付出了一切的这个角度来考虑问题。但是如果有一天我们换一个思路，这是老娘想要的一切。
对吧，我没有一个原生家庭来帮衬我，我没有好的父母来给我依靠，一切只能靠我自己来经营，这就是我的江山。我生的孩子永远是我的。如果我能把我生的孩子培养好，把他们要培养成一个幸福的快乐的健康的人，我这一辈子对吧？我这一辈子我自己好像就脱离了原来的那种痛苦，就是你的原生家庭不好，但如果你能给孩子一个好的原生家庭，你就打破了这个魔咒，你就成功了，你的人生就圆满了。我怎么能够让我的人生圆满呢？姐妹们啊，就是动用一切你能动用的资源，利用好一切你能利用的人。我说这个话，利用两个字听上去不好听，但是这就是。
特别简单粗暴有效的，你现在能运用的就是你老公、你公公、你婆婆。除了你老公、你公公、你婆婆之外，你谁也用不上，对吗？在这种情况下，如果你改变不了现状，你没有办法舍弃两个孩子，你不可能离家出走，你不可能离婚，你不可能甩掉这两个孩子的话，那你只有一条路，就是要跟他们的关系搞好，同意吗？就直播间的其他姐妹们同意吗？只有这条路，就是跟他们的关系搞好，演好这出戏。
你不要想着是我在委曲求全，怎么怎么样的，你就记住龙飞姐这句话，我只要把这出戏演好了，我就有好的生活，我的孩子也有好的生活。
啊，就这意思啊，刚刚也有其他姐妹从不同的角度来说这个问题，确实啊，公公婆婆帮衬你们是情分。如果公公婆婆啥也不帮人家两口子喜欢到处旅游唱歌跳舞，你也没啥办法，因为你也没有什么规则可以去，可以去约束人家，就这意思。